Since we rounded to the nearest 10th of a foot, our gasoline height, our level,
would be 2 and 7 10ths of a foot. Amazing work if you found that one. We start
setting up out proportion by looking at the number of gallons, the height, and
the square of the radius. We know the number of gallons varies directly with the
height of the gasoline level and the square of the radius. Since it varies
directly with these two amounts, we want to make sure we list those both in the
numerator. And the square part is really tricky. You want to make sure that you
square this radius. Once we have this proportion we can plug in the values for
each case and solve for the unknown. In one case the tank has a radius of five
feet, so we plug in five here. It holds 4,700 gallons, here and has a height of
eight feet. So the height one is eight. In the second case, we're looking for
the height of the gasoline level so that will be H. At some unknown height, H,
the radius will be four feet, so the second radius is four. And the number of
gallons that the tank will hold will be 1000. So gallons 2 is 1000. Now, we want
to solve this equation for h. We square the 5 and the 4 to get 25 divided by 16.
Next, we multiply these 2 fractions together to get 200 in the numerator, and
16h in the denominator. We cross multiply to get this equation. And then,
finally, we divide by the coefficient of x to get our final answer. We get a
decimal for our answer and we want to round to the nearest tenth. Because the
value next to the 6/10 is a 5 we round up. If this value was less then a 5 then
we round down and keep our answer as 2 and 6/10th. But for 5 or greater we round
up so we get 2 and 7/10. This is the level for our gasoline take that holds a
thousand gallons and has a base rate of 4 feet.